ken Sims doesn't do nine-to-five
this is his idea of a good day at the
office
for over 20 years he's ventured into
active volcanoes across the globe to
click samples of molten lava studying
this stuff is one of the best ways to
understand what's happening in the
center of the earth and the process that
protects us from the Sun pretty much
that whole bottom terrace now is
completely covered in brand-new lava
flows yeah with the new lava flow coming
around against the wall there we'll have
to watch out the lava is intensely hot
roughly 2,000 degrees it will burn
pretty much anything on contact okay
heading over I'll go over just towards
the edge here we'll have a look
whoa
holy
it's just opened up on that side hasn't
it yeah totally whoa
now can I'm pretty certain that there is
absolutely no where we are going down
there that is without doubt mission
impossible okay well they're wrong
cancel admission just anybody with half
a brain wouldn't go down there the new
vent means Ken can't take samples from
the lake but he doesn't need to the vent
is firing fresh lava right at it
there's a lot of lava bombs around here
it's just covered with bombs
Wow I'm can see the vent from here it's
really rocking and rolling
[Music]